corps avec une belle sélection de livres
avec vous tiphaine faveur vous avez
passé vos vacances à lire à lire pour la
bonne cause un livre des livres qui font
peur oui des livres qui parlent de
fantômes et de fantômes qui permettent
un petit peu de grandir et de dompter
ses peurs justement et elia tu en
emménageant dans cette maison ne va pas
du tout avoir le choix puisque il
emménage au 109 rue des soupirs et que
cette maison est hantée de fantômes à
domicile et oui c'est le titre du livre
a justement le livre de monsieur tanner
yom ni dumont c'est publié par casterman
alors rassurez vous ces fantômes ne sont
pas vraiment méchant ni vraiment
totalement terrifiant ils sont plutôt
loufoque et ils prennent assez
rapidement ce petit eliott en affection
il décide de s'occuper de lui un petit
peu comme des nounous vous le voyez là
et lui font le petit déjeuner voilà il
s'occupe vraiment de lui parce qu'en
fait ces parents sont tout le temps en
déplacement et délaissent un petit peu
le petit garçon qui à seulement neuf ans
non mais ils le prennent tellement en
affection qui font cuire toutes les baby
sitter qui se présentent
le problème c'est qu'un jour arrive une
effrayante dame baby sitter qui
s'appelle frida bonne chose ah oui c'est
la tatie danielle de et du coup cette
bande dessinée est uniquement dégradé de
gris donc c'est quand même assez un
petit peu gothique voilà c'est c'est
assez flippant aussi mais c'est très
drôle
franchement ça va beaucoup plaire aux
enfants à partir de 7 8 ans j'aime
beaucoup cette saison le père mieux que
je n'aime pas non plus les enfants qui
se plaignent qui rit qui bouge dans tous
les sens
fata n'aime pas les enfants quoi voilà
nom elle est pas les enfants et elle
aime pas non plus les fantômes assez
quant à lui clairement je vous le dis
donc qu'est sa venue dans la maison va
quand même semer le trouble alors c'est
la nouvelle bande dessinée de monsieur
times qui est très connue des enfants
puisque c'est lui qui a signé mortels
adele qui est quand même déjà un livre
vendu à environ 2 millions d'exemplaires
pour vous donner une idée c'est quand
même d'accord le gros tabac d'accoutumée
m'en parle beaucoup du goncourt mais on
parle pas cette ces livres là voilà donc
c'est la bande dessinée à se procurer du
moment pour le la fois partir de quel
âge 7 8 ans et puis sans limite d'âge un
super l'absence l'amitié la chasse aux
fantômes
au menu de cette bande dessinée qui
s'appelle en rappel c'est en effet free
des soupirs super vous allez à la
rencontre des fantômes aussi ce matin
certains même ont poussé la porte d'un
manoir paraît-il hanté d'autres mondes
dans des trains c'est un truc un peu
bizarre qui s'est passé pendant cinq ans
j'ai laissé à la la je suis monté dans
le train fantôme carrément de didier
lévy et pierre vazquez donc ça c'est
publié chez sarbacane alors vous savez
c'est cette célèbre attraction des fêtes
foraines en ce moment derrière c'est la
fête en ce moment c'est la foire de
dijon j'ai testé le train fantôme il a
trois étages carrément ah oui non non
c'est un truc de fou
ça fait super peur enfin voilà bah alors
celui là est encore plus terrifiant je
pense parce que si vous voulez au départ
c'est un manège abandonné il ya une
petite fille lina qui qui va quand même
parce qu'elle elle veut retrouver son
grand frère jonas qui a fugué en fait
suite à une dispute avec leurs parents
donc elle se donne les moyens
tant pis joue le tout pour le tout et
elle monte dans ce train fantôme elle se
retrouve dans les profondeurs avec des
monstres effrayants vous le voyez et
sont tous plus effrayants les uns que
les autres c'est le black magic à
l'express oui c'est loin du train c'est
assez terrifiant
et c'est d'autant plus terrifiant qu'en
fait c'est illustré par des gravures
donc ça donne une impression voilà très
particulière et bien ce monde terrifiant
c'est le monde un peu de la mort du
désespoir qui peut parfois saisir les
ados donc l'idée c'est de savoir si elle
va réussir à rattraper son grand frère
adolescent j'ai trouvé ça assez
intéressant alors ça demande un petit
accompagnement quand même parce qu'on
jette pas ce livre dans les mains d'un
enfant de 8 ans comme ça mais ça peut
permettre aussi de parler la relation
entre un enfant et un grand frère ou une
grande soeur adolescente et puis des
idées noires qui peuvent parfois bon
travail et les enfants vous savez des
fois ça travaille la mort le désespoir
tout ça donc c'est un livre assez
intéressant et en même temps
esthétiquement c'est très beau le train
fantôme c'est ça voilà on peut pas
l'oublier ce petit nom la vallée des
fantômes encore
vous nous en parler le pire ce serait
peut-être pas avoir peur des fantômes
finalement pour les enfants ne pas avoir
peur du tout est ce que vous savez quand
même que la peur ça permet aussi de ben
voilà de se prémunir du danger mais loue
la petite héroïne de ce livre là de
bruno pellegrino et rémy farnos ce qui
est publié à la joie de lire et bien
elle n'a peur de rien alors c'est le
thème de ce livre les mystères de la
peur c'est que ba cette petite fille à
la peur ni des inconnus ni des fantômes
ni même de se faire écraser par un train
alors bas à ses deux papas un jour ils
se disent bon là il faut consulter
là vous avez un papa côté de vous la
mode étant donc ils l'envoient en cure
dans un institut très très étrange qui
s'appelle l'institut pétoche institut
poteau oui ça affiche la couleur
directement que tenus par une dame qui
s'appelle madame amigues dallas alors
amigues dallas a fait référence à la mi
dalle qui est cette petite glande qui
normalement vous donne corps vous envoie
le signal de la peur et alors là bas on
règle les cas désespérés en les
allergies chronique le vertige et c'est
avec justement des méthodes extrêmes des
trains fantômes des grands 800 ceinture
ceinture même histoire de valade est
d'aider des charges définitif quoi c'est
vraiment un roman que j'ai adoré et
notamment la relation entre les
différents enfants qui sont en cure et
la petite fille et ses deux papas qui
sont très inquiets voilà comme tout
parent de se dire ma fille elle est les
intrépides
mais ce jeune elle ressent pas la peur
allez rapidement peut-être un dernier
ouvrage peut peut-être devenir soi-même
un petit fantôme pourquoi pas ben on se
dirait pour nous peut-être que ben ça
permettrait de ne plus avoir peur par
devenir soi-même enfin je sais pas si
c'est moins terrifiant par mois mais
alors non c'est beaucoup plus terrifiant
dans ce livre là pour les ados qui
s'appelle bout de nice mme hibou et bien
on se rend compte que c'est terrible en
fait c'est un roman de science fiction
qui invente en espèce de paradis pour
les pour les ados de 13 ans voilà c'est
assez déroutant mais je le conseille
pour les ados c'est super j'aime
beaucoup le titre en tout cas bout très
bien merci tiffen fort pour cette
sélection livre à retrouver aussi
évidemment sur le net en pianotant
france 3 point fr et puis sur les
réseaux sociaux facebook twitter
instagram se passe comme ça vous
retrouver fontenay référence c'est
exactement vous avez toutes les
références